I always say the number one skill of an
entrepreneur ability to sell or
communicate number one people always
kind of dump on what he call the fast
food industry if I had to do it again I
go barf at McDonald's you know if you
want to stay small be the smartest guy
on the block Juanes or get a mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent add
something so today let's learn from one
of the best Robert Kiyosaki and some of
his best life-changing advice meant to
me Robert
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one always be a student you wake up
tomorrow morning and you're on the
street and you have nothing you don't
have a single contact and your network
all you have is the knowledge and
experience that you've had throughout
your career how do you build up from
there well a bender many times so it's
no big deal you just figure out what's
needed I'm watching you go do it
you know I'll people always kind of dump
on what we call the fast-food industry
if I had to do it again I go work for
McDonald's and the reason I go work for
McDonald's you know whether that's seven
bucks an hour or 15 I don't really care
I don't really like McDonald's food but
they have the best business systems in
the world
how else can a company take virtually
non college-educated people and build a
fast-food industry across the world and
they have the best system so right
inside little McDonald's you can learn
everything you need to learn about
business except for the management side
of it so I just go work it Donald so I
can learn even more so I look at life as
learning I'm constantly learning
you know I reading constantly studying
constantly I spend most of my time with
entrepreneurs I don't spend my time with
people who complain about the economy
you know so nothing really change I just
go back to being an entrepreneur rule
number two give a lot I don't know what
the heck but people think about money
but that's what I get a lot of is kind
this well you know money is not
spiritual I'm just saying it's your
attitudes you know the person's attitude
towards money I make a lot of money but
I give a lot you know what I mean
in fact it goes to biblical principle
the more you give the more you receive
so when I meet somebody who's not
doesn't have any money it just means
that they're not giving something yeah
you know so a lot of times there's
people who would like more but they're
not giving anything so they're like my
poor debt you know he belonged to the
labor unions and he wanted to work less
and get paid more
well that's anti-religious to me yeah if
you want to get paid more work more give
more that's how I see it also if you
want to learn to have more self-love
check out my 254 series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
I don't cheat on my wife I don't cheat
on my customers I don't cheat people I
don't cut corners if I can't do
something I'll tell you upfront if I
screw up I'll tell you rule number three
hang out with the best and if you want
to stay small be the smartest guy on the
block and that's why most accountants
most attorneys most doctors never get
rich it's because they're too narrow you
know they're experts and toenail removal
or something you know I mean before my
attorney that got poor guys at a is
Judah I knows jack about side of that
whereas I never had Emma I fought that
high school twice I can't write it's IRA
novella my writer today but the reason
I'm pretty good is because in the
military we're taught to be generalists
not specialists so when I sit down with
my team I have accountants I have
attorneys I have media guys I have IT
guys I have graphic designers and all
this so I operate as a team since I
don't know anything so in actuality
being a great entrepreneur means I could
be the laziest guy and I can know the
least but I have to have a very smart
team which is the ring finger around so
because I was never smart I had respect
for people who are smart and a lot of
times I meet a students and they think
the smartest guys on planet earth and
that lack of respect what keep them
small and that's what most corporate
guys want to do stay small you know
you're gonna get a climb that corporate
ladder you gotta beat the other guys
with a job and it's all that stuff it's
not the way an entrepreneur only works
it's its corporate it's school system
you know you gotta beat up for the
greatest best grades I don't have to be
the best but they have to hang out with
the best rule number four master sales I
always say the number one skill of an
entrepreneur ability to sell or
communicate number one because sales
equals income so if your sales are down
your incomes down but it's not just
selling your customer you got to sell
your employees that's really tough you
know and then next is selling my
investors so I'm selling investors and
selling employees and selling customers
and I'm selling myself you know I got to
talk myself into it I don't have the day
I don't have the pleasure of being down
entrepreneurs gotta be up because if
you're down employees know customers
know at the market knows it so number
one is sales but when you look at the
big picture there's three things an
entrepreneur must learn number one is PR
and what you're talking about is PR the
other the other day Fox News interviewed
me to find out if I would endorse my
friend Donald Trump for president you
know much that's worth you know they
they call branded us
Kiyosaki Rich Dad and Trump yeah that's
incredibly priceless you know so getting
PR is a number one skill under that is
marketing and marketing does is like
advertising they want to set the
customer up to get ready to buy oh yeah
oh yeah I saw that key I had I want to
buy a Kia I want to buy some land and I
want to buy you this so the customer is
now primed to buy it that's marking his
job then the last thing is a sale so if
you've done a really good job on PR then
you've done a great job on marketing the
sale is like that you know they walk in
they buy but if you have no PR and you
have no marketing you have
the pound pound hard close a lot mr.
customer you know you know today's
changing business environment you know
you should buy my insurance oh no and
people today hate sales pitches more
than ever before
so the number one sales job of a true
entrepreneur is develop your ability to
get PR I'll say it again most
entrepreneurs are not good at sales
they're horrible at mark and they have
no idea what it is and they can't get
any PR and so they struggle and again
sales equals income to the crash I mule
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip is learned through
trial and error how does an individual
that sort of opens themselves up to
learning and you know actually make sure
they don't get sort of roped into the
wrong advice and the wrong teacher well
unfortunately as part of the process you
know I've had bad teachers as well as
good teachers oh that's part of life
that's real life it's like how do I know
she's the right woman for me should I
marry her I don't know
or is he the right man for me I don't
know if you don't know you don't know
and sometimes you don't know it till
after you get married it's the same as
money there's no real answer to that the
trouble is those schoolteachers tell you
there's an answer there isn't an answer
there's trial and error does learning
gonna make mistakes I've made a lot of
mistakes but I've never been very good
for me because I've learned from what
schools tell you if you make mistakes
you're stupid yes when it's a poor they
don't make enough mistakes or if they
make a mistake they don't learn from
them now I have a special bonus tip on
how to be a team player with Robert that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one who do you
need to stop hanging out with number two
what's one small test on an idea that
you can try this week and number three
what will you commit to learn
to improve yourself this month and if
you liked this video and you promise to
take action after watching it give me a
hash tag believe down the comments as
well I'm one of those kids who doesn't
like school you know school is good for
people who like school but here was my
poor dad head of education PhD on the
governor's Board of Hawaii and all this
stuff and his kid me and I'm flunking
out of school because I can't read I
can't write I said I couldn't read I
couldn't write I was bored out of my
mind you know how's this Hey
so what I did instead was that's when I
met my rich dad was my best friend's
father and he used these things called a
game see games are the best teaching
tools see when I'm playing this game
this is how the rich taught their kids
battle strategy is called chess my rich
dad taught me to be a rich man playing
Monopoly we played Monopoly our hour
after hour you know the formula for
great wealth of Monopoly is for green
houses one red hotel so today in Arizona
I own 8,000 green hotel I mean green
houses and several red hotels I just
play Monopoly for real so that's the
power of a game because a game engages
me mentally physically because I accept
the mo thing emotionally because when
somebody knocks me out I better wake up
you know I made a mistake and
spiritually because it's spirit that
wins now if you so saw Golden State play
that play they you know everybody I love
LeBron James
I love Cleveland you know but one guy
cannot take on a team and I think LeBron
scored 60% of all the points in assists
and all that but a better team Beatle so
when you look at business business is
the same thing but this is a team sport
I have to have got accountants gonna
attorneys good marketing guys good tech
guys great staff after have great
leaders you know the trouble with most
entrepreneurs are sulfa
boid so they quit their job and you know
in America they the SBA the Small
Business Administration says of 28
million small business owners
28 million 24 million are classified as
non employers emerge their one-man team
you know the bail like this guy said
okay I'm gonna take you on are you crazy
but that's what most entrepreneurs are
trying to do because that's what they're
taught to do in school to be the rugged
individual you know in school I was very
successful as long as I could cooperate
at test time but in school cooperation
at test time is called cheating in the
real world the guys have the biggest
team win so all I focus on is putting
the best team together meanwhile a lot
of time to a students in school that the
doctors and lawyers are sitting there
all by themselves they're sitting ducks
but they're entrepreneurs Genet means
this a mindset tactics strategy I went
to military school I'm a former Marine
so I think like a military operation
which I love chess so most most
entrepreneurs you know they have this
job okay I'm gonna be an entrepreneur in
this case is massacre because they went
to school they'll learn to get a job and
they take tests on their own they have
to be the smartest that's like the
LeBron James
I don't want being a smartest guy in my
team but I want to have the best team
and that's why I win most of my games
that's great I think like this and the
doctor stick like this and fight yeah I
got you man yeah for some reason I get
the sense I'm gonna win
[Laughter]
if you want to know robert's five
secrets to be a successful entrepreneur
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there if you
can't sell you don't make money period
and the statement entrepreneurs have one
thing in common they keep going